let me just get everything up
that i need here
huh hope folks are doing okay
let's ah okay
how do i look in terms of positioning
and framing and let's bring that down a
little bit
that's a little better let's let's put
let's bring you folks
nice and close
there we go i'm liking that
huh hey everybody
i hope you had a nice holiday you know
what we're gonna
bring that up just a little bit
there there i like that better
i think i'm going to keep fiddling with
this
sorry all right
huh okay
hope everybody is doing all right
um we're almost at the end of this year
how crazy is that
hmm oh what the hell is that
it was a fuzzy in my water
the latest youtube sensation adjusting
cameras with council of geeks i'll start
a trend
i'll do it uh so
there's a couple of things that are
gonna go on in this one and i'm gonna
keep adjusting it
i'm just i'm just gonna keep doing it
i'm gonna go here and i'm gonna tilt it
down
because i find this angle
uh slightly more flattering and
all about my ego so if i'm not finding
it flattering
it must be changed
this is not negotiable this is the way
okay there we go i think for the sake of
my ego i'm finally done
fiddling with it okay let me pull that
in a little bit closer
so don't have any particular topics
going on this time
um i do have some unboxing to do
because i have stuff that was sent to my
um to my po box
so i do have that to uh to do and you
folks will get to
see some of that i'll probably go uh
quiet during some of it especially while
i read notes because i know so
i i know from experience sometimes
people don't want their names read out
so
unless unless part of the note says it's
okay to read this you may just
get to watch me read
very enticing i know uh
how many of your decisions would you
say your ego is responsible for well if
you were to ask my ego
it would claim all of them
uh i i have a sizable ego i'm
well aware of this this um oh
uh this shirt this top
this was a christmas gift
my mother gave me this the earrings
my partner liz gave me
uh and the nail polish uh it's not the
usual smorgasbord of colors it's just
two
because these were the two colors that
my kid
my daughter got me for christmas so
already kind of showing off christmas a
little bit and i did
okay i kind of i kind of did a bit of a
brag on this one by putting it in the
thumbnail for this but
i really like this and obviously it's
it's foam that's why i'm able to grab
the blade
but
uh just the fact that i now own this
makes me
very very happy uh
and it's good length on it too it's
about it's about as long as my
um as my broadsword is which is nice
all right done bragging on that i think
uh
good to see folks here festive spirit
yeah
yeah i'm i'm hoping to keep that
uh that feeling that vibe going
tenth doctor compensating
i don't have to compensate
i'll leave it at that shouldn't have
even said it
um
uh now do you believe me that
nbc did the grinch yes i now believe you
oh
dang it you know what i just realized
something all right just in time for
vera to brag about the length of her
weapon yes you did
meg um give me a sec i'm not
changing the stream or anything but i
just realized i screwed something up
over here
i'm just gonna fix that real quick
because i'm madoofis
there we go that's better um
looking forward to tonight's theme being
all the camera angles
um well there i can't show you all the
angles
because i'd have to be wearing pants to
be able to do that
now here's the real question
was she joking
um
never a dull moment i like to think not
do you like the potato no
no i don't the pating design does not
work for the vibe they went for the
creature
it doesn't it doesn't work at all
um so i suppose i
should grab something for unboxing
which means i also get to
flick open knives which i gotta find
my butterfly knife one of these days i i
have one
i have some ideas of where it might be
but i never i never
think to retrieve it for these
on new year's instead of saying happy
new year we like shout you manji
is that a joke hold on uh
i had a question i lost it i'm not gonna
be able to keep up with these
is that joker figure the creepy
black-eyed one from season four
um no uh it's not
it's just the the distance you have on
it makes it look that way
have you have you read the torchwood
book almost perfect nope i've never read
a torchwood book
i got socks for christmas i'm free i
we all got socks for christmas at
my christmas got a fifth doctor celery
lapel
oh that's nice pants you mean
leg prison i'm gonna remember that
uh do you think wearing do you you think
not wearing pants is racy i have a
theory
but that whenever we see stick persons
too peg for the real stew is naked
i could buy that actually all right
we've got a few things in here
got a package we've got bubble wrap and
we've got
a card so bear with me while i
sort this out i i flip my camera around
the opposite way to how i normally have
it so i keep looking over here
expecting the camera to be here but it's
on this side
so i apologize that i'm going to keep
looking off to the side
i don't mean to me mean to
i can speak you know what
ah cheers
okay
huh
thank you very much i think i'm not
going to name only because
i i don't have clearance to do so
explicitly in the letter but
thank you that is amusing um i'll read
the card i won't say what's wrong and
says
it's it's xmas and a clever funny
wonderful person just sent you this card
and yes yes i agree with that
oh you went to the same school of uh of
wrapping that i attended i see
just smash the bits together and
lots of tape lots of tape tape covers
all sins
that's at least true in burlesque where
you need to keep pasties on
tape is uh is very vital
all right
that having been said this there we go
and ah boy this is
this is mildly okay there we go
or do i have to be able to lift the
whole thing right up i'm gonna have to
cut the other side
come on come on there we go
lovely
oh my gosh okay
so all right so i spotted the
the wonder woman i didn't notice right
off
and it says vera wilde oh
wow oh that's really sweet
oh this is good this is going to get
featured um
with with many a uh hydrating beverage
and if i thought i could safely transfer
from this to this without losing
anything i would
i however don't trust myself that much
um did you think doom [ __ ] was satire at
first
i don't know if i ever genuinely thought
he was i hoped
i i i hoped against hope
that that he was satire
uh alas i'll tell you the last time that
threw me off though was
uh jessie jender used a clip of him in
one of her videos
or at least it was an audio clip and i
was prepared to swear
that she altered the audio so as not to
out whoever she was making fun of
and when i asked her about that she's
like no i use that that is the exact the
audio exactly as he did in his video
i mean she didn't even tell me who it
was i was like oh it's doom [ __ ] isn't
it
oh god the scenic route a movie about
vera wilde
uh starring jonathan groff
uh at the very least could you cast
somebody younger than me
i think he's around my age
he might be younger than me i'm old
ah damn it how quickly would the stream
be demonetized if you were to
accidentally slice yourself with a pen
knife live on camera
uh sadly not as quickly as it would be
if i were to pan down and confirm
whether or not i'm wearing pants
that would get it demonetized much
quicker
uh if they make an it chapter three
would you go see it why would they make
it
i mean the story's done there were two
halves they told both
what is there to even do
i mean maybe out of morbid curiosity
like what are you doing but
for the most part no
that's not happening is it
you got me nervous now i'm almost
30 in a month so i'm feeling the same
feeling if i'm old even though you're
older than me
i am almost a decade older than you
so look i'll grant you this 30s is when
you start feeling
the aches and pains and you start
realizing oh
my slowed down even if it wasn't great
to begin with it gets worse
uh apparently it
could be a prequel about pennywise in
the past oh that sounds terrible
ew no
no like maybe
not old is you well you have aged like a
fine wine
carowind i am aging like milk
uh maybe they should have casted us
pennywise instead of bill skarsgard
um what if neutronic and
doom [ __ ] married each other oh no homo
bro
like if they do in it chapter three
the only way i see that is basically
for the sake of riffing on it because
the other two i've gone and seen
with a friend and if she really wanted
to see the third one
okay maybe otherwise no
no that's that's not a thing
um completely forgot about this stream
did you have a nice
lovely christmas item very honestly i
had a
very normal christmas because
the people who i see during the
my circle of contacts it's myself
my kid her mother liz my mother
you know the people are all the people
who i'm seeing normally so
we had a normal christmas
it was completely unaffected by coven
next halloween you should go out as a
sexy
it's just my that's just my daily outfit
i also got a fantasia hoodie
red lights in them i'm curious about
details on this gay christmas sweater
i'm 20 you adults promise you're not
going to be a bad influence on me
i promise no such thing
cancels here in the uk oh i am sorry to
hear that
i don't know if it's just me but the
audio on the live is randomly watching
it with
okay let me grab another thing
and groan as i do because i am
very very very old oh
okay i think i can say who this is from
because this
is from jessie gender this is this is
coming open already um
i sent her after hyping it up
of maple rum from a distillery right
here in town
so that she could try that with eggnog
oh no am i buffering okay
seems to be all right now am i back
hello
yeah you are oh good
oh okay anyways let's see
oh oh my god okay
[Laughter]
oh god i gotta figure out where to put
this stuff i'm so running out of space
on these shelves
so we have
my doctor oh
oh oh capaldi i miss him
and i don't i don't know where in the
heck
she found
farscape figures but i'm gonna have to
find a home for zan
too and i like i suspected this might be
in this box because she got herself a
craze and part of me wondered
did you find others is that what's in
the box
um that i was waiting to be opened um i
i was i was not expecting the doctor
though and
oh i'm gonna have to rearrange this all
again it's a fun
issue to have because it means i'm
getting sent more lovely things
um i mean hey i've already had to put
more stuff up here um some of which i've
had for a little while i'm actually i'm
gonna tilt you a little bit
ah so like the gender fluid tardis
and the heart those are new
um because i'm i'm trying to
have a more complete run of things on
the shelf for
people to get to to see
but um i am i'm
really running out of space i suppose
oh i don't want to have to do that
though like
i suppose i could move or remove some of
the bigger stuff like attach a coma
or totoro i don't want to do that though
ugh i'll figure it out i want
i wonder if i can get away with making
putting the tachicoma more in the
background
a bit like my gizmo is over here
that might be something to try because
he's he's
forefront i don't know i got to think
about it later
there's a weeping angel behind you on
your shelf what where
it didn't move i i swear not when i was
looking at it anyway
uh favorite non-numerical doctor i.e
uh nobody numbered between 1 and 13.
um
that's a good question um
i don't know i really need to re um
watch scream of the shell shalka
and get my bearings on the shoulder
doctor again
because i remember liking him but it's
been a long time if a box sounds like
it's ticking
it's from me but it wasn't meant for you
oh good to know ben
i got a pair of doc martens and a drink
dispenser
like they have in bars for my water ooh
fancy
jonathan groff is 35 years old
of course he is
[Music]
have you seen the john barrowman guesses
his
lines game on the doctor who youtube
channel no
i need to check that one out he's a hoot
um i did get i did get to see him
um uh when i went to
terrificon last year
he was a riot uh
should nerdtrotic rename himself to hate
erotic
look if new stuff is i don't know if
they're being asked about
because like new stuff has gone on i
don't know i don't care i don't follow
them i never will
like
nerdtrotic doomcock fish tv
bowler strike i don't care i don't care
what they do
no i take that back i'm frustrated by
what they do and i wish they didn't do
it but i refuse to give them attention
so that's that's where i'm at at that
um my friend i got my friend into
watching american horror story loving it
thus far
um that's good i like i should try and
get back and catch the seasons that i've
missed
i've still only seen the first five all
the way through
i met barrowman at boston comic con in
2017 he was an absolute
like yeah he he really was okay
oh jeez okay that one's heavier
it's heavier or i'm just weak and old
and
pitiful and should be working out
instead of drinking so much
water
all right
i got the marco polo the crusaders and
the myth makers
doctor who novelizations oh cool
[Laughter]
oh god i suspected
that'll keep me busy
thank you there wasn't a note with this
one and it looks like
if there was a return address it got
plastered over by
other things so but not the first time
i've gotten this i suspect from the same
person
well let's see if this is the same setup
the knife is getting a workout
part of me is tempted to get one of the
big swords down to customer boom
but that would actually be legitimately
hazardous as
much fun as i might have
john barrowman has blessed this chat
we should all be so lucky actually on
that note what are your thoughts on
american horror story coming i
hated coven i really did i did not like
coven at all
and i i got really annoyed that
basically all of the
like merch for a long time that i could
find related to
american horror story was all coven the
only good thing was um
was kathy bates
i didn't like coven at all the actors
did their best with it
but the progression of the story was
crap a ton of narrative cul-de-sacs that
went
nowhere it couldn't remember its own
damn rules it kept changing them it was
ah it was a
mess did not like coven at all
um do you watch the ball drop on new
year's um
sometimes um i probably will i have my
kid
for um
for uh new year's this year and she she
though i
i had heard from her mother last few
years that she likes to try and stay up
to see the ball drops so i'll yep we'll
see how that goes
oh this is the place where the cool kids
come
guys sit in the corner stepping on a ice
cold bang galactic gargle blaster
while waving my sonic screwdriver
aimlessly i don't think you should sonic
and
um pan galactic gargle blast at the same
time i
i don't think that's a good idea
do you think gotham basically became the
show of
the loophole um oh
ah lost it
uh you can't do the joker okay let's
basically do the joker
yeah yeah they did rather they
really really pushed the limit on that
what's the ball drop on the clueless
team scott
teen scott so in new york city on new
year's eve there is a
ball that in times square that
lowers it during the countdown nine
eight seven six five four three two one
and it hits the bottom of its thing and
yeah happy new year and it gets
televised so
it's a thing
ah
all right i i this is the point where i
have to give up trying to keep up with
the chat
because i
it just goes back too fast and if i try
and if i try and stick with it
i get behind on where things are so if i
miss a question if it's desperately
important
ask it again at me but also don't spam
the chat
so there's a balancing act to be had
here uh
what's your favorite fifth doctor moment
um
when he regenerates i don't have to
watch him anymore no
that's cruel i don't actually think that
i don't know
he stands out to me so little i'm sorry
uh i've been buying a few prop weapons
for a project recently the shop owners
think i'm arming a revolution with prop
weapons
that'll be a short-lived resolution
resolution revolution oh
speaking of which prop weapons
nerf gun now hopefully it will not take
me as long
to repaint this as it did with my last
one which is
tucked away in under there actually let
me see if i can get that out without
knocking a bunch of stuff over
ah only knocked one thing over
so this is the last one i had with my
custom paint job on it
uh which i'm quite fond of and quite
happy with and i have
similar plans um
for this but like that took me
years to get around to doing that so
but and also like this thing
i'm not gonna fire it in here but like
it shoots these little things
this is not messing around this sucker
like they're soft their nerve they don't
hurt but like
this thing does not lose momentum on the
shot very
very quickly way way more propellant
than the darts
shift that i'm missing so many questions
uh perhaps close the stream by
destroying the camera with one of your
guns
oh boy i really want to spray paint a
nerf
gun black so i can shoot stuff and
pretend i'm in torchwood
their guns do look kind of nerf-ish at
times don't they
uh well i am getting swords and air guns
so oh
fair enough
i think you're wonderful stay fabulous
thank you very much
imagine if doom [ __ ] was a classic error
doctor who villain why
i mean he's not that far off from omega
his plans make about as much sense it's
hard to
watch the wizard of oz knowing what
happened to judy garland
i mean it is one of those movies where
if you know enough about the
um the behind the scenes stuff i can't
make it hard to watch
um it's one of many reasons that i will
probably never watch dancer in the dark
i know a number of people recommended it
on my
um uh musicals
video but aside from the fact that i
have absolutely no interest in it i
think
lars von trier is a terrible terrible
terrible
terrible terrible director um
knowing that you know what she claims
happened on set
while she was there i'm like no no i'm
not gonna watch that
i wouldn't enjoy it and it's also one of
the
multitude of reasons why the shining is
garbage
although to be clear the shiny would
have been garbage even if he
had not harassed and tormented shelley
duvall to the point that she
was losing her hair
it would still be a crap movie because
it is
i will not be taking questions at this
time
i saw a post how lala ward should have
been the actual fifth doctor agree or
disagree
um i don't know
and not to knock lala ward but like a
lot of her
a lot of what worked with her was
specifically her chemistry with
the fourth doctor when they had it
before they started fighting
but i don't know like especially because
i don't know there would be something
weird about there was this character
and then a time lord adopted her face
and then to have another time lord adopt
the
that face that a time order adopted from
another person it becomes a weird
jenga thing and it like kind of falls
apart for me at least
i'm sure she would have done fine what's
worse glee or grease i don't know i
don't watch glee
i've never watched glee i will not watch
glee you'd have to pay me to watch glee
hold on i got one other thing here ah
was saving this one
so let me
duty
[Music]
ddd
oh this looks like nice stuff
oh there's a few things in here
we i think that's glass
pardon me
oh
i don't know if that'll be able to be
seen but it's kind of got
i think that's a b
on it well that's pretty
have you watched the cgi daleks series
on the doctor who youtube channel i have
not
one of many things i have yet to get
around to okay where was this
before that fell over it was
okay all right deal with that later
obviously um what else we got in here
oh oh that's pretty
oh that's so colorful
oh my
uh so this is a pin
and it is a rainbow wolf
with moons and stars and little dangling
stars on my daughter's gonna be so
jealous of this oh that
is so awesome oh
i love it we got here
aries fairy resemblance
oh oh she's got horns i love that
all right there's one other in here
there's one other item
oh i actually really need this
okay so
she they here's the reason i really
needed this
this is wood so this shouldn't
shine in my lights the way my other
she they pins do because part of the
reason that i don't wear them more often
is
they catch the light and they shiny you
can't read them that shouldn't happen
with this
this oh oh this is going to make regular
appearances
thank you i do know i do know who sent
me these
um and i don't
uh i don't know if they wanted to be
identified so i won't do that but
i i do know who sent these and they are
really wonderful
thank you thank you very much
ah okay i need to
get that placed over there put that with
it
that stupid thing go when it fell uh who
knows
who cares have a drink
thinking of getting a t-shirt that says
i heard 2020 to confuse it in white
people
i think you might get attacked in the
street for that one
what is it okay what is it with the not
my doctor youtuber questions
is there a thing going on i'm unaware of
i'm not like offended or anything i'm
just like
i'm befuddled ever so mildly
wesley or giles oh
depends on the measure we are judging
them by
i like giles better overall
but you know what wesley's got a killer
arc
as a character one of the best in
television
it's oh that is close
trying to measure anything close to
objectively giles would
just beat him out but barely
uh who would you rather play on broadway
sweeney todd or king george
ooh
my ego says sweeney todd because more
stage time
plus it'd be really nice to kill people
on stage i feel like that'd be cathartic
i haven't gotten to kill anybody on
stage since high school
and even that that was a pistol duel and
we both died so like
no real sense of victory to that
it's a crazy idea sweeney tied sweeney
tied
sweeney todd starring the cast of the
doctor 12 at sweeney todd missy as mrs
lovett delgado masters judge turpin
that'd be very cool um
all i can guess is that with the
upcoming new uh new year's day special
they're showing up from recommendations
again unfortunately oh
yeah that that would explain things uh a
little bit
uh charleston i
i'll tell you why i'm kind of
it's not the reason i present the way i
do now i present the way i do now
because
this is me and this is how i'm more
comfortable most of the time these days
but back when i looked more like this
i know for a fact there were people who
avoided my channel because they saw the
thumbnail or they saw the
icon image and thought oh god it's
another one of them
them being people like
bola strike nerdtrotic doomcock
etc etc etc and
it's nice to know that on site you would
not
mistake me for one of those
so that's that's a nice side effect to
looking as fabulous as i now do
you may now shower me with praise thank
you thank you
ah you played hamilton in high school uh
no i'm old
you and your ego have good communication
with each other i
you know we we keep in touch
uh in sweden you get to throw mrs lovett
in the furnace that's
that's fun too uh
oh it's like there's plenty to do
throats to cut
people to toss into furnaces so much
blood to get on hands
but the work waits
and i'm alive at last
and i'm full of joy
then who did you uh play in high school
where you shot someone i was in a one
act
which was an update reinterpretation
thing of
hamlet and i played the equivalent of
claudius and in
that hamlet and i shot each other in a
duel at the end
because being a one act it didn't have
what's his name laertes in it
if you performed in a play of little
shopper fours which character would you
play seymour audrey
or or the plant honestly um
i always kind of figured i'd end up as
the dentist
mm-hmm
sun be a dentist
uh i wanted to play sweeney but i got
cast as
beetle bamford instead hey look
if you get a named character you still
did good
and act like there's nothing wrong with
being in the chorus
chorus can be fun saw someone on twitter
say that the master uh is
catra to the dr zadora
that's somebody else's head cannon
that's what that is
what's the weirdest torchwood plot
you've seen or heard
probably still day one which was the
weirdest and the stupidest
it was really awful friggin
alien sex gas
chimney
are you going to be doing a review of
avatar the last airbender season two in
the break room channel i will be
i am a little more than halfway through
i think i'm 13 episodes in
um so that'll that'll probably be out in
january at some point
um like i've got i've got reviews i've
shopped for the break room that i have
to edit
get those out and then there's other
stuff to get around to watching like
more of avatar and i need to finish the
hbo
watchman um heck i shot
my review for the owl house like a
couple of weeks ago
i still need to get that up it's ugh
oh yeah what's the best shakespeare play
midsummer night's dream
and also one of the few that he could
claim much originality on that one and
the tempest
because pretty much all the rest were
histories or they were recycling fairly
well known plots romeo and juliet was a
was an established plot from i think an
italian play
and that's not to knock what he did with
it but i'm saying
i feel i feel
not having known the man and not
really being a scholar of any kind
but i feel like midsummer night's dream
and the tempest
are the purest distillations of
shakespeare it's not being filtered
through
history it's not being filtered through
a well-known established already
successful story
i feel like that's him
in the purest form or at least i like to
think so
plus i just love puck so much
so so much how now spirit with a wander
you
um have you ever tried fish and chips
have i tried fish and chips
i i honeymooned in london and had fish
and chips
ruined for me
because i do not remember the name of it
i'm hoping i am crossing my fingers that
if i could get back on the streets of
london i could find it again
but there was just this little pub just
just a normal pub off a street in london
i had the best fish and chips of
my life even better than the other fish
and chips i had while i was in
london they were incredible
and i almost never ordered fish and
chips anymore because they're not
as good as that was like
when i lived in new york there's a fish
and chip joint
run by a couple of british guys called
assault and battery
and it's supposedly like as good if not
better than
english fish and chips and it was good
don't get me wrong
but it wasn't as good as that pub i
can't remember the name of
god that was good
have you seen cloud atlas i love cloud
atlas i've seen
it i love it it's a hard movie to
recommend
it takes a very specific kind of person
to ever recommend that movie to because
it is so
lyrical and weirdly constructed
and dealing with metaphor and themes
more than it is dealing with narrative
and plot even though there is still
narrative and plot to follow
and that's without getting into the fact
that some people are
i would say rightfully uncomfortable
with some of the
use of makeup to alter someone's
apparent
race even though i understand why they
did that in the context of that specific
film in terms of the ideas and the
themes that it's dealing with
it's a really tough movie for me to
recommend but i
really do like it are you watching his
dark materials nope i only did the first
four episodes because i was paid to
watch them
i didn't really get into it that much
have you worked soul
not yet that is on my to-do list i'm not
gonna get to that until january though
uh well that okay i might watch it
before then review won't be out until
january
national treasure three the search for
beerus beloved fish and chips pub
uh get me nick cage
also i played puck vera's jealous yes
meg
yes i am
you tease
i once killed someone on stage i got off
on a technicality
uh
if you could act as one of the villains
from doctor who
in a future episode which villain would
you like to dress
up as for me i'd always like to try
being a cybermen
okay so if we're going for like
the sort of group things the things that
there's like a standard look
for so your cybermen your
daleks your zygons
um et cetera et cetera et cetera
see i'm too i'm too tall to
be a santaran otherwise i would have
gone with that
um
cybermen but mondaxian cybermen
they're just creepier
you cannot defeat us we are stronger
and more cunning than your earth people
oh you're back john i didn't realize you
left
is it weird that capaldi's my favorite
doctor but there's not that much i love
about azera i don't think that's that
uncommon
i actually do like kizera i think he
gets better every time i love series 10
i love it to death um but i do get that
that there are a fair amount of issues
during his tenure so i don't
i don't think that's that uncommon a
position to take
um have you seen are you planning to see
wolf walkers
i have seen it i liked it my kid
loved it i don't think i'm going to do a
review specifically on it but it is
going to get
mentioned in an in an upcoming video
i'll leave it at that
um i played juliet my school's romeo and
juliet we sang
spice girls songs and i had isn't she
lovely saying to me by romeo
everyone from the blade cringe at the
memory to this day
that's um that's cringe worthy
have you read atlas shrugged nope and i
won't
i someone tried to pay me to read that
i'd actually
charge a premium even above what i
normally charge for book reviews
if you were to be cast as the doctor
what would you do with the role
personally
i like to play the doctor much darker um
well i
you already know what my look would be
if you follow the channel enough
um because i've debuted in some of my
doctor who list
um videos with the the red coat the blue
vest
white shirt the the ridiculously over
the top
um sort of neck piece
uh i've got my own
sonic oh and
gotta sometimes i have to fidget with it
to get it to light
let's see how we get this
ah there we go
i love this thing um
i've got boots and all that other stuff
for that as well so i know what my look
would be
if i was the doctor
personality wise
um it's that's
i was gonna say it's a bit harder to
nail down it's not i have ideas
the thing is i might eventually do
something with those ideas
don't get your hopes up for something as
elaborate as a fan film i'm not that
good a director and i don't have the
resources
but you know i i i kind of i'm
keeping some of that um in my back
pocket
who made the custom sonic i got off etsy
i cannot remember the name of the store
off the top of my head
uh sometimes i have to fidget with it to
get it to light that's what she said
well you know as long as it's charged up
uh whatever happened to that brown wig
i used to wear during burlesque numbers
in vt pride it's in my closet
i haven't gotten rid of um
really any of the wigs i've had for the
last few years
um but i don't wear them anymore because
i mean like why what look at look at
these luscious locks
and they're mine you rub my fingers
through them you you can
you can pull it it doesn't come off
uh instead of a fan film could you make
a video saying what you would do
with who uh i created three series with
tom ellis
as my doctor i am planning uh to do
for next month a video with what my
pitch for series 13 would be
um depending on how that does maybe at
some future point i'll elaborate out
into um
what i would do with my own version of
the doctor
are you blonde no i'm light brown um
how it looks depends on the light well
hmm
i am i i have light brown hair with an
increasing amount
of white not even gray
when my hairs go they go white
and it's way too many to count at this
point
um i need to check the discord
before i forget oh you you felt that one
did
did you caroline all right i'll be back
in a minute folks
let's see get this pulled up
so reminder and the usual plug if you
support me on patreon at two dollars or
more per month
you get access to the discord which
includes a guarantee that your questions
will be answered
as opposed to running the risk that i
don't ever see it or get to it in the
normal chat
in addition to other perks as well such
as getting to see the docket early
voting in polls
early access to most videos etc etc
etc i'm trying to figure out a new way
to push that a little bit
growth on the patreon has been stagnant
lately and while it is covering my bills
and i am so grateful for that
i'm not able to build up a savings so i
don't have a safety net right now
so i i'm hoping to get into a position
where
if something happened i wouldn't be
screwed
but anyways
all right let's see
what is the weirdest movie you've ever
seen my boyfriend and i watched holy
motors last night
and that didn't just take the biscuit it
practically took the entire cookie jar
i've heard of holy motors
um
there was a movie i saw called
nowhere which was
very weird and
terrible it was like i think it was
supposed to be like a spiritual sequel
to doom generation which i never saw but
i guess more people have heard of
uh nowhere was awful
but it was very strange not in a way
that was
interesting um
following your watchmen video i was
wondering about
fidelity in adaptation at the opposite
end of snyder you can probably find
kubrick who for example
had likely no interest in the text of
the shining
but my question is what would you say is
your favorite adaptation from a
literary medium into film
oh that is
that is tricky i think
if you okay trying to think i i'm gonna
end up giving several answers because i
i'd have to really think about that
honestly i gotta write that down to to
put that on the
on an eventual top 10 lists uh top 10
movie adaptations um
but i i'm the ones
coming to the forefront of my mind um
there's the last unicorn which the book
is better
to be clear but the movie is really good
it has the heart of the book absolutely
and is actually
very loyal to the book minus really only
one segment as far as what actually
happens
in it but it does suffer the usual thing
that happens with a
uh a novel with a really strong
narrative voice
which is also at the heart of say
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy awards
it's not just
what is happening it's the words being
chosen and how it is described
and that doesn't the impact and the
effect of that doesn't translate to film
but even knowing that that's a really
good adaptation
i'd also cite the lord of the rings
trilogy and partly because of the
changes it made
it is much more of an action-adventure
story
in the hands of peter jackson which some
people
can and do [ __ ] about but
that's a better fit for film the
continuous nature of film
benefits a lot from a more propellant
forward momentum angle on the story so
focusing on the action scenes and the
adventure elements
was a good way to translate it to film
and to
tone down what is frankly at times
really dry books
all due respect so those are kind of be
the ones i'd cite
have you seen head over heels it's one
of my favorite movies
i feel like i've seen that title but no
i'm not
even entirely sure what it is all right
i'm popping on back to the chat
i love your big finished reviews and
would love to see you review
the eighth doctor stuff uh also if you
have read the new virgin adventures made
in the 90s i mean like i
it's so hard for me to get around to
books which is bad because there's one
that i need to get back into so that i
can do a review that i was commissioned
for it
um but i i would like to get back into
big finish
but um i do i do need to prioritize my
commissioned reviews for a bit
um before i get back into stuff that
would just be for me and right now
big finish would be unless somebody
wants to pay me to review some of it
uh there was also a broadway production
of how the grinch stole christmas now
see that makes more sense to me than the
live
show although i suppose if there is a
broadway there will be a live that
one follows the other
which is better star trek the original
picture book or shrek the movie
adaptation
i'm sorry not tricks not why did i say
star trek
i saw shrek and my brain went star trek
shrek the original picture book or
strike the movie
adaptation i've never read the picture
book so i do not know
this is tasty water um
i hate to be so persistent what's the
eta on the owl house review
i know you shot and all you need to do
is edit it i will try and have it out
next week
i'm not promising but that is what i
will try to do
okay i'm sorry to leave you waiting
like a lot of people are waiting on a
lot of stuff and i feel bad and that's
one of my goals going to 2021
is to catch up on that stuff
so thoughts
thoughts on the former soviet union
i don't know
i don't even know what to do with that
question not that it's bad i just
i just don't know what to do with that
uh
i'd quite like something like your sonic
i like the idea of a tissue compressor
that is worn on the wrist
did you watch the second showing of nbc
the grinch live no
no like first of all
i don't have i cut the cord i don't have
normal tv coming into the house
so i'm not sure how i would have been
able to
uh anyways but even if i could no
god no
i didn't tame the other shrew in high
school and we did a gender swap on the
role so i ended up playing catherine
huh
that kind of has my attention a little
bit
have you watched a musical called sing
street i have not
i haven't even seen once uh yet
my thoughts on the soviet union two
stars
[Laughter]
two stars may not be sustainable
dennis o'hara's max the dog just sounded
wrong
dennis o'hare as
the grinch's dog max
i
ah
yeah okay
uh watched star trek voyager in the day
i didn't really
um my girlfriend my last two years of
high school
watched it and i saw a couple of
episodes vicariously
through her um but no i never really got
into it
have you heard of seussical the musical
i have seen
the junior version of it because my
daughter um
not this past summer but has done
um children's theater
during the summer and she she was in
that
and she actually uh
got to be max the dog now
strictly speaking max the dog doesn't
have a part in the show as written
but they did the thing that any
clever um director of kids
should do which is you have a bigger
chorus than the show actually calls for
and so
you come up with characters for them to
be in the background so they're not just
generic whatever so a kid was cast to
the grinch
and my kid was cast as max and they were
just in the background
or they actually they chased each other
across the back of the stage at one
point
but um yeah so i i'm familiar with
seussical
what's your pick up line struggling to
get a boyfriend
okay you do not do not
come to me for dating advice
and i don't even mean i'll have bad
dating advice like i have no
business telling anybody anything about
like
i haven't dated since
i was in college
it's been like
17 damn years
because coming out of college i was with
um my daughter's mother
for a while and then i
started seeing liz we had known each
other i've never
i've never been like in the dating pool
i've never used a dating app
i've never tried to pick somebody up uh
in a bar like
i don't have pickup lines i don't i
don't know how you go about trying to
get
dates i know how you go about like
trying to hook up
i know how to do that or at least i did
a long damn time ago probably none of
that works anymore but even then i
didn't have pickup lines
oh lord
um
uh how did the milestone quest in the
puzzle marvel quest work out for you
they worked out pretty well
ace actually they let me boost a lot of
stuff um
i am i am i now only have two
four stars that aren't uh
no sorry three four stars that aren't
champed um
and and i ha i have every single
card um at at least one uh
thing i can't think of words um because
i picked up
um adam warlock
earlier today actually snagged him
um out of a out of a pack so
yeah no i'm doing i'm doing quite well
there
thoughts on rocks like rocks the
physical item that you find outside
rocks are great
that is all
[Laughter]
uh would you do a mock review of atlas
shrugged
that's actually just talking about
bioshock and you're drunk
okay first of all if i was going to talk
about atlas shrugged at all
seriously or mockingly i would probably
need to be drunk
actually i don't know if that's true
maybe maybe maybe
i could approach the original work
with some degree of
analysis or trying to take it
semi-seriously
what i can't take seriously is anyone
who seriously adheres to
objectivism as a philosophy for life
because i'm sorry
and i'm going to be really blunt about
this i've never known anyone
who wasn't like objectivism is the best
thing ever who wasn't either
a teenager and teenagers get a pass
because they're learning how to be
decent human beings
or if they were an adult anyone over
anyone at the age of 25 or older
who loves atlas shrugged and touts
objectivism
is an [ __ ] introduce me to
one who isn't i've never met them
that's that i think that's the thing
about that book regardless of its merits
as an actual piece of work
it it just empowers [ __ ]
uh thank you for the
rock's question that's for an inside
joke with my friends
okay what's better rock paper or
scissors
it's always contextual
do you think the idea of the
spider-verse will translate well to
live-action i feel part of the charm of
the spider-verse was the animation and
its style
um well i mean they're they're obviously
doing
some version of a multiverse with the
live action i really wish they weren't
it's not going to be the same because
part of
what made it so fun and into the spider
verse was
it wasn't just they came from different
places each one got to be a distinctly
different animation style
some of them were similar to miles you
know peter b parker
and spider-gwen but then you have the
monotone look of spider-man noir you had
the manga
inspired look of uh penny parker and
then of course you had spider ham
like i loved that they could each look
distinctly different
in just from the very conceptual design
not like as a different costume but just
like from the ground up
everything about them looks different
and you can't do that live action
it doesn't mean that there won't be ways
to make it work but like
animation allows you to have that quick
visual shorthand
that works really really well
i tried reading it years ago because it
was mentioned in gilmore girls i hated
it he couldn't finish the first chapter
so we're ripping into atlas shrugged
nice
uh
you need to be drunk and high at the
same time to get through glee
uh i believe it you know what's
something i realized
this is not an indicator of anything i
plan to do before i say that
it was just something that occurred to
me
part of the reason why for the last nine
years i would
um i mean not the only reason not really
my thing anyway from being completely
honest but part of the reason why i
would turn down
offers of say edibles was paranoia
being tested at my job because even
after
the degree of legalization that's
happened there's still companies can
still have policies where they
test you and can fire you for
having that in your system even if it's
legal they're allowed to do that my
company did
now that i am my own boss
i actually could start taking that stuff
i don't plan to i have zero plans
at all but that just occurred to me a
few weeks ago despite having been
self-employed
since july
strange this is for the doctor in
distress fund
pass the collection around do a proper
commission that'll bump it up the list
otherwise i don't know when i'm going to
get to that
oh oh i finished that didn't i oh
there's still stuff in here that note
i'm flying to vermont was space cakes
what it's water
uh you doubt that's what
how what what why would you doubt the
sincerity
hydration is important children
uh
is it bad that i named a character after
my old head teacher
and the character is a cult leader no
makes sense to me
have you re-watched caves of vandrossani
recently i haven't
i do own it uh i should but i haven't
i doubt everything you drink
[Music]
what is the best and worst days of the
week i don't know anymore because when
you're self-employed at work from home
the uh the days
they lose distinction
um if i didn't have
you know the the weekly ritual of of my
kid
um you know coming to my place or going
to our mothers i might lose track of
days altogether
would you play beer pong but with jack
daniels i would not play beer pong
period i'm sorry it's gross
it's really gross not just because it's
beer like it's gross
in fairness the other day i woke up and
thought oh it's christmas eve isn't it
christmas really did sneak up
sorry about that minor freeze hopefully
it's back
um i do need to wrap it up soon though
you could collaborate with any youtuber
who'd you pick
oh
dominic noble i think would be top of
the list
currently
oh i'm almost hot excuse me
ah
and on that note uh i think i will
wrap it up not lindsey i like i don't
know what i could seriously do
collaboratively with lindsey ella she
would just blow me out of the water
if she ever wanted to like i don't know
use my voice
because she does that on occasionally
have people read quotes and stuff
um like i'd be down for that but like a
more involved
collaboration i don't even know what we
do
anyway
why oh okay so there's one thing i'm
going to address
because i didn't address it in my review
and ben asked this and so
there's about to be minor spoilers
for wonder woman 1984 and i do think
very minor because what i'm going to
talk about ties into something that was
in the trailers
so this is super minor and does not
really come up as much as you think it
should
but to answer your question ben he asked
why are some people saying there's a
rape scene in wonder woman 1984
and he's asking because he hadn't seen
it so
calling anything in that movie a rape
scene is
honestly hyperbolic here's the
issue and there is an issue of dubious
consent in the movie
and that has to do with the fact that
okay
if people need to clear out spoilers
incoming again they're very minor
but there's your warning so steve trevor
comes back
and we knew that we've known that from
the trailers but the thing is he doesn't
suddenly just come back to life
he is occupying another man's
body which means
that if steve and diana
have sex that's with the body of another
person and that person
did not consent to that
now a couple of things worth noting
one there the movie is structured in
such ways
i don't think you can definitively say
that they did have sex there was
kissing there was cuddling
definitely it's not definite there isn't
like a clear-cut
sex scene there's still issues of
consent with just making out with
someone who
can't consent to it so like there's
still issues but again that's part of
why i feel like it's hyperbolic
to call it a rape scene but here's the
thing aside from that
even if even if
they definitively do not actually have
sex
there's still big issues of consent
because steve is put
voluntarily and in situations that both
he and diana know
are life and death he's putting another
human being's
body at risk and that person did not
agree to have their body
be placed in danger so even if it's not
sexual consent there's still consent
problems around the way they brought
steve back
and the thing that's weird and i didn't
talk about this in the review because i
didn't really start thinking about this
element of it until after i shot my
review
which is up in the break room of geeks
if you haven't seen it but the thing is
really weird is
the fact that steve is occupying another
guy's body
really never comes up
in any substantive way i had honestly
kind of assumed
that what would happen is at some point
later on
there would be this aspect of well steve
can't stay because
this isn't he's in a stolen body
he can't just have that but that
question never really gets brought up
at all um i i was talking with jessie
jender about this and she posited
something that makes a lot of sense to
me
which is that um
steve taking over another guy's body as
opposed to just appearing in modern
times
is probably a holdover from an earlier
draft of the script where that
element more directly impacted things
its impact got shaved down but was never
completely excised from the script
i can't prove that that was jesse's
theory and i think it's pretty sound
that's the only way i can think of
because as far as what steve does and
how the character works
and how he interacts with diana and what
happens with him over the story
the fact that he's occupying somebody
else's body doesn't impact
really anything and doesn't even really
get addressed
properly so it feels like something
that's
that is a holdover it feels like an
appendix
it's very strange again
while i will not deny issues of consent
i do think that anyone who is choosing
to just flat out
label it a rape scene or to label the
makers
the writers the director or the actors
in the movie as rape apologists
is being hyperbolic like
i understand the ground on which they
are making this claim
from but they're overshooting
i feel um and then and
part of the reason that frustrates me is
i do think there was a very legitimate
conversation
to be had about what qualifies as
consent
because even just making out this has
turned into a longer rant
i'm just rolling with it even just
making out with someone who has not
consented to do that
is sexual assault that is a consent
issue
there is a conversation to be had about
consent without
labeling it rape
because i feel like labeling it rape
just
it just shoots the conversation off in
this other direction that isn't
productive
there's an actual meaningful
conversation to be had
about consent for things
that are minor like kissing
without consent like endangering
somebody without their knowledge or
consent those are consent issues as well
and they deserve as much of a
conversation as anything else
it's not necessary to label this as rape
so okay
i think i'm done
[Laughter]
but yeah uh notice you didn't complain
about
cgi cappers and kristen wiig in your
review no i didn't cuz
if i was gonna complain about anything
in that fight scene i would have
complained about how
dark they made the scene to cover up the
cgi
that's what i would have complained
about but honestly that didn't even
stick in my head that much
max talks on the broadway production of
the grinch of course he does
that's very stupid uh
last time i got high i got stuck in a
mcdonald's toilet screaming for help
not realizing it was an electric door
and i had to push a button to get out
oh dear
whoo
uh yeah it it is time to
excuse me to wrap it up
um russell t davies is the steven
spielberg of doctor who
moffett is the nolan marcatus is the tim
burton what do you think i
like tim burton more reliably than i
like mark gaidas written
episodes of doctor who so i'd question
that one
um can i say they is instead of they are
i mean you can but it's gonna sound
weird to most people
like just use they the way you use they
it's okay they singular does exist
it's an existing thing it's not a new
created thing
for pronouns it already exists
they as a singular has been around
forever if you
see a lost dog you don't know the gender
is oh
i hope they find their owner you find a
wallet and you turn it in and you didn't
look at it to see
the license on any boy i hope whoever
lost that wallet i hope they find it
singular they it's an existing thing
don't make it complicated it's already
there
ah anyways
all right i need to stop
thank you very much for joining me
congratulations
on making it this far couple days left
you can get through the rest of this
year you've got this
thank you so much for joining me
take care of yourselves and please
remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
and i just run the meeting and until
next time this council
is adjourned